we've been talking for months now under
the guise of the Ukraine Fiasco about
bribery bribery and extortion committed
by the President of the United States
the Trump administration has now gone
completely beyond parody on this issue
and Donald Trump is looking into making
bribery legal now when I saw the
headline I thought this is from the
onion this is a Saturday Night Live
sketch but it's not it's been confirmed
including my advisors to Donald Trump
check this out from Vanity Fair Vanity
Fair writes a forthcoming book called a
very stable genius Donald J Trump's
testing of America by Washington Post
reporters Phillip Rucker and Carol
lennick reports that Trump has
complained about existing rules and that
he clashed with former Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson in 2017 when Trump
pushed to scrap the FCPA that's the
Foreign Corrupt Practices Act it's just
so unfair that American companies aren't
allowed to pay bribes to get business
overseas Trump said according to a
passage published by The Washington Post
we're going to change that the law is
designed to prevent individuals and
businesses in the u.s. from paying money
or offering gifts to foreign officials
as a way to win business overseas
critics of the law complained that it
puts US businesses at a disadvantage in
places where bribes are customary now
you might think there's no way this has
to be made up and yet Donald Trump's
National Economic Council director Larry
Kudlow admits that this is something
they're looking at he says quote we are
looking at it we are aware of it we are
looking at it and we've heard complaints
from some of our companies you know that
Nixon phrase when the president does it
that means it's not illegal this is
going a step further this is if the
president wants to do it or wants his
friends to be allowed to do it he'll
change the law to make it not illegal
this is not getting nearly the attention
that it deserves
Trump was impeached for a fiasco that
includes bribery extortion although
that's not actually in the impeachment
articles and his economic adviser admits
that they are looking at making bribery
no longer illegal or a specific form of
bribe
anyway imagine all of the absurd things
that this could open the door to listen
bribery is no longer illegal so I
shouldn't even really be considered
impeached anymore
now again Trump was not technically
impeached for bribery I understand that
it was abuse of power and obstruction of
Congress I'm kind of kidding or
exaggerating but the bribery that Trump
is trying to legalize is bribery to gain
foreign favors in places where bribes
are relatively commonplace this is the
underlying spirit of everything that
went down with Ukraine and the Biden
smears and of course there's a Trump
tweet for absolutely everything back in
October of 2016 a couple of weeks before
the 2016 election Donald Trump tweeted
alongside a picture of Hillary Clinton
and an article about her quote
pay-to-play collusion cover-ups and now
bribery so crooked I will drain the
swamp we now know it didn't quite work
out that way would Hillary Clinton have
tried to legalized bribery it's hard to
imagine she wouldn't have done all great
things Hillary Clinton was far to my
right there's no question about that but
she wouldn't have done that she wouldn't
have appointed the Supreme Court
justices Trump is appointed she wouldn't
have appointed the extreme and
unqualified according to Bar
Association's justices judges that
Donald Trump has supported appointed to
lower levels there would have been
really important differences and of
course Donald Trump wants us to believe
that he's really worried about
corruption in Ukraine while he wants to
legalize bribing officials in countries
like Ukraine and others super believable
that the priority for Trump in Ukraine
all along was dealing with corruption
right when he's trying to legalize more
of it here in the United States let me
know what you think leave a comment if
you're watching on YouTube otherwise
send me a tweet at D Pakman after the
break you will not believe or maybe you
will who is now promoting climate change
denial videos algorithmically while
decimating the David Pakman show channel
you probably only need one guess to
figure out who that is that's coming up
next